[Applaudissements]
bon en voyant arriver comme sa petite
barbe utilisent plutôt décontracté et
pour les plus fines lames écologistes
parmi nous un jean d'une marque toujours
assortie de 100 made in france certains
parmi nous pourrait dire celui-là je
serai bien entrepreneur social c'est
qu'elle dirait ça il aurait totalement
raison je suis co gérant d'une petite
société à rouen qui s'appelle tout en
bo1 entrepreneur social ça peut parler
de quoi ça peut parler de finance au
service de la société avec l' épargne
solidaire ou les monnaies locales qu'on
peut créer nocives d'agriculture à
taille humaine où comment recréer le
lien entre les consommateurs et puis les
producteurs directement ou encore de
réduction des déchets n'est ce pas où
comment créer des modèles économiques au
service de la société
mais c'est vrai que si on se pose une
petite bière ensemble et qu'on apprenait
à mieux se connaître
verrier qu'en fait je suis pas très calé
par exemple sur tout ce qui est voiture
ou encore dernière musique d'actu par
contre il ya des choses qui
m'intéressent vraiment la quête de sens
et de cohérence
les vraies rencontres ou encore la
rigueur intellectuelle
quand on essaye d'aborder un sujet de
société et et de ça aussi vrai qu'on en
parle 1 c1 est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
entrer dans un paradis une façon de voir
les choses ensemble pour ce petit pitch
qui se résume en trois mots tout est lié
tout est lié en fait je me suis aperçu
que que ce soit dans la vie ou dans la
vie d'autres les choses au fur et à
mesure se liait et je voudrais vous
partager tout simplement trois
rencontres qui ont profondément changé
mon quotidien et ma façon de vivre les
choses
la première d'entre elles c'est avec eux
jean-philippe on était trois quatre
potes en retour de week-end dans une
voiture et la conversation commence à
partir sur les élevages intensifs et
industriels à niveau moi à l'époque
végétarien végétalien quasiment
militants temps vous dire que le ton
monte assez rapidement je suis assez
ferme dans mes arguments
ils sentent un peu attaquées chacun
répond comme il peut et on est très
content de voir une petite aire
d'autoroute pointé deux kilomètres plus
loin
tout le monde sort de la voiture on
décompresse moi je fais quelque part je
trouve ça un peu parce que ça sera
encore cette affaire et puis là dessus
j'ai jean philippe qui a rien et qui me
dit fais toi même tu sais ce que ce que
tu dis là c'est c'est génial c'est
prophétique c'est ça mais mais quand tu
dis t'as aucune compassion et je vais
j'ai dit ça s'est passé il a il aurait
pu me dire plein de choses il aurait pu
me dire écoute mec t'as dit ça tu as 22
ans prend un peu de poil au menton est
clair pas tu reviendras nous barrer
mais là j'aurais eu à lui répondre juin
lady était justement bien sûr à 22 ans
là je rêve d'un deux ans et dont on n'a
pas encore d'assises à la subissons mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'un pro et c'est pas
intéressant il en russie pu le dire mais
toute façon il ya ya trop de combats
on peut pas tous les mener en même temps
mais là j'aurais pu aussi lui à répondre
justement par jamais autant
qu'aujourd'hui nos façons de vivre à
être consommés ou a eu un impact sur
l'ensemble du monde du coup j'aurais
trouvé à lui répondit il a fait un pas
de côté et il m'a dit est simple guen
n'a aucune compassion
en fait il avait raison pourquoi parce
que je voulais bâtir un vraiment doux ou
l'amour et la vérité se rend compte à
justice et la paix s'embrase un monde
stylet et stimulant mais pour réaliser
ça je voulais y arriver en tapant sur la
tête des gens pour qui quand fans
d'asile et c'est bizarre mais ça marche
pas comme ça
alors tout simplement j'ai je suis rendu
compte que vous êtes tension qui
m'habitait en fait se transformer en moi
c'est assez vindicatif se transformait
donc quand quelqu'un ne pas forcément
heureux et donc quelqu'un qui a des
bains aucune compassion pour les autres
je peux ce que ce genre la gentille à
relier tout simplement cheval à
reconnecter c'est mes émotions
est ce que je vivais intérieurement au
service tout simplement de mes
convictions conviction que j'ai essayé
de de poursuivre bien sûr avec un ami on
a écrit un manifeste qui s'appelle
changer le monde depuis sa jambe
cet engagement le premier c'est prendre
soin de soi
le septième c'est sortir de sa chambre
et entre les deux cinq engagements sur
le pourquoi et le comment agir au
quotidien
le manifeste fait son petit bonhomme de
chemin il est téléchargé et la deuxième
rencontre
je reçois un coup de fil de régis régis
c'est pas le même délire c'est plutôt le
haut avait dans une chambre
d'agriculture qui s'intéressent à
montmagny fester 2 décembre le lin peu
pour discuter avec moi un petit peu de
mal il reste 1 et j'entends que ces pros
à bienveillant mais dans un petit café
sympa prend le manifestant main il dit
il dit je vais prendre les engagements
que je connais le moins mal agriculture
et élevage pim et puis la nuit ils
commencent à mettre une fessée
il a ce chiffre-là comme de céréales
pour un nombre peau pour créer un kilo
de viande aux oui c'est la viande bovine
mais combien c'est pour les poulets et
il attaque il enchaîne les chiffres
géniaux que j'avais cité dans le
manifeste en blanc suite à cette petite
leçon
c'était pas l'ancêtre qui est tribune
jeunes poussins je voudrais pas parce
que régis doit avoir entre 45 et 50 ans
donc je serai pas ça mais mais c'était
quand même de l'ordre d'une vraie
correction servait bienveillant et là et
il appuie qui blanc dans la conversation
et puis il me dit l'aigoual qu'est ce
qui compte pour toi est ce que c'est
d'avoir raison ou est-ce que c'est
d'essayer de comprendre je vais dire oui
c'est vrai ça alors avec des amis on a
on va créer un événement qui rassemblait
des militants là on met d'ailleurs
environ 4 carrés sont bien des militants
de diverses obédiences vous rappelez
peut-être qu'à des manifestations qui
ont privé notre société le taffetas par
exemple traiter transatlantique ou
encore à l'époque il y avait le très
connu ouverture du mariage aux personnes
de même sexe qui va pas réussir à se
parler celui là on a réussi notre coup
ou encore la reconnaissance des animaux
conscient de la sensibilité animal dans
la loi bref on a rassemblé des personnes
militants et dans notés dans dix bars
éviter de paris montparnasse et on était
une cinquantaine on aura été tous prêts
à dégainer un certain contexte mais là
on commence à détendre un peu
l'atmosphère tu vas rencontrer quelqu'un
que tu connais pas depuis tu partages
avec une bonne nouvelle enfin book bonne
petite ambiance qui secrètent et lahonce
répartis par thèmes et on pose deux
questions aux gens la première c'est un
qu'est ce qui t'a touché au coeur on ce
sujet qu'est ce qui t'a vraiment marque
partage et la seconde c'était comment
est-ce que tu as pris position sur le
sujet qui a intéressé
et là c'est marrant de voir que ces
échanges la à partir de ces conditions
là donc fait que que les dés retour sur
cette soirée c'était plus de l'ordre de
ses marges et pas forcément changé
d'avis mais mais je comprends mieux
comment il voit les choses
ou encore c'est marrant je voyais plutôt
côté négatif de ça aujourd'hui je
m'aperçois que que ça peut être tout
simplement meilleur que ce que je
pensais
en tout cas ce que je m'aperçois que
régis à reconnecter en moi à relier en
moi ce serait de l'ordre de 2
d'une façon d'aborder les rencontres et
les enjeux de notre société
chers amis je voudrais faire un petit
pas de côté pendant un instant pour nous
interroger un tout petit peut-être
certainement pas en arrivant avec mes
gros sabots en disant c'est ça qu'il
faut faire
peut-être avec le courage en même temps
de d'essayer de poser des questions par
exemple en liant des sujets quelqu'un
qui s'interroge sur les intrants dans
l'aviculture par exemple ou comment on
peut aider des consommateurs et des
agriculteurs à - m de produits chimiques
dans leur salle
est-ce qu'on peut pas essayer de lier ce
sujet là à la façon dont ce qu'on met
dans notre corps je pense bien sûr à la
façon dont ce fan mais pourquoi pas
aujourd'hui par exemple aller lançant le
sujet à la pilule contraceptive
là c'est vrai ça vaut le coup de se
poser la question parce que autant d'un
côté il ya des solutions sig est par
exemple de créer davantage de lien avec
les consommateurs de payer plus cher un
produit autant des méthodes naturelles
sont plus écologiste et avancent plus
humanisante et j'aimerais un peu poussé
un petit peu le débat est ce qu'on n'est
pas rentré dans une sorte de culture du
déchet je pense bien sûr à la façon dont
mon linge au quotidien de temps en temps
pas tout le temps mais ça arrive on crée
des déchets est trop souvent on les
jette on en fait des montagnes dans le
sens physique du terme puisque la
production en france et qui donnait chez
apple et il me vrai os au mont blanc
mais est ce que ça peut parfois se
transformer pareil dans nos relations
les uns avec les autres ou quand on sort
avec quelqu'un de moche est la personne
au canton l'aiment plus par exemple on a
un peu une relation consumériste et
j'oserais un thème immensément intime
pour beaucoup mais qui est lié par
exemple à l'avortement quand 92 % des
les enfants détectée par le diagnostic
prénatal sont détectés trisomique qui
sont tués à ce moment là est ce que est
ce qu'on est dans une pensée racines qui
serait pas de l'ordre du chef d
j'ai pas de réponse à ça je voudrais
juste quand société ensemble on ait le
courage de se poser ces questions tous à
tous ses engagements un peu militants et
pas forcément pacifié moi même à la
troisième rencontre qui est qui et
j'espère la plus belle et la plus
durable qui est celle avec une belle
colons alors c'est pas un oiseau c'est
ma fiancée
c'est très chouette ainsi j'espère que
ça va durer sur le moment ce n'était pas
forcément bien partie parce que de fait
c'était pas facile et elle aussi elle
avait ses dossiers
et puis au fur à reproduire la mesure
des choses se sont un peu pas s'y fier
parce que ce que collombat à relier en
moins réunifiée c'est peut-être de
donner là là juste finalité de tous ses
engagements
en fait ce qui a été avant de l'or par
exemple de choisir de ne pas prendre
l'avion pour des enjeux écologiques
en fait en quoi est ce que ça vient
servir notre couple aujourd'hui encore
est ce qu'on vient le mettre dans une
relation unifiante et et pareil pour
l'ensemble des gestes de façon de se
nourrir au quotidien
en fait notre couple 1 c'est devenu le
lieu du don de soi le lieu peut-être
l'expriment la la fine pointe de notre
humanité au l'être humain se donne lui
même
aujourd'hui si avant j'étais encore dans
l'espoir que mes actes
porter des fruits et que le manifeste
remet à télécharger et que les choses
changent aujourd'hui je me rends compte
que c'est beaucoup de mots avec collomb
c'est vrai que on a plus tant à coeur de
porter énormément de fruits dans nos
relations ou autre mais ouvrez que ce
fruit là soit pas amer on voudrait que
ce fruit là dans nos échanges soit soit
vraiment vrai con qu'on arrive à
partager des relations pacifiées si on
peut inspirer d'autres par une façon de
8,5 alors c'est vrai que on prendra
peut-être pas l'avion pour visiter bible
et qui sait on fera peut-être avec notre
famille si on en a une
le tour du monde en deux ans en vélo
ira bien tout ça m'a même un peu à une
pré conclusions avant que vous proposez
de vivre un exercice tout son sens un
exercice 5 sens propre du terme car
cette petite réflexion
perso je crois que c'est profondément en
se connaissant soi même c'est à dire ces
zones de ressources ses émotions ses
limites ses désirs ardents qu'on peut
mieux s'ouvrir mieux s'ouvrir à des
sujets de société ou à des sujets divers
qui nous touche dans un premier temps et
puis au fur et à mesure en s'ouvrant
mieux à d'autres sujets qui nous
touchait pas forcément au départ et
quand on est capables ensemble de
réfléchir dans une démarche assez sujet
on peut pâtir je vais te communauté
l'association de société pourquoi pas
une révision
une vision qui vaut le coup de se donner
une vision hyper stimulante des choses
et de cette vision qu'on a qui fait qu'
on sait d'où on vient et rousset où on
va vers de cette vision alors dans ces
cas là tous nos gestes quotidiens les
plus intimes presse deviennent prennent
tout leur sens prennent toute leur
mesure parce que qu'on soit en train de
de prendre soin d'eux quelqu'un faire
attention à ce qu'on met dans son
assiette de prier en fait on comprend à
quel point tous ces instants là sont
profondément important et en même temps
qu'on prend conscience d'à quel point
c'est vraiment important ont conscience
que tout le monde s'en fout on changera
pas le monde que ça marche pas comme ça
et que c'est pas grave parce que dans
l'histoire de légumes verts c'est pas si
important mais qu'entre ces deux pointes
le très important et très chute il ya
comme un espace c'est à dire notre
propre réponse la journée notre espace
de créativité dans lequel on va engager
notre liberté on pourrait dire aussi
notre dignité humaine et ça ça en
prendre la mesure
c'est vraiment génial alors charles oui
j'aimerais partager un petit exercice
spirituel que je fais chaque soir avant
le coucher il s'agit de relire ma joie
ça me donne de prendre
conscience de la la mesure de cet espace
intérieur de créativité que j'ai vécue
aujourd'hui
alors en ce sens chacun selon ses c'est
propre c'est rohff conviction et avec sa
propre façon de vivre je voudrais vous
proposer ce petit exercice alors je vous
propose est tout simplement de détendre
le faire la route avec ceux qui ont les
jambes croisées pourquoi pas de se
mettre dans une position dans laquelle
on se sent à l'aise tous un peu et de
revenir sa jambe simplement autour de ce
1er au 6 mai on veut continuer
vous fermez les yeux ou les garder
ouverts si ça vous hais les rentrons
dans un premier temps en repensant notre
journée où on rentre tour d'une mauvaise
on peut goûter intérieurement même
ressentir à tel point
aujourd'hui on a eu des relations ou
autres qui ont été bonnes
à quel point de s'émerveiller des trains
et à tel point c'est bon
toujours en pensant à notre journée
percevoir les lieux où on n'a pas
vraiment été dans notre oui on n'a pas
vraiment donné le meilleur de soi on n'a
pas vraiment aimé est tout simplement
que ce soit soit même vous autres à dieu
tout simplement demandé pardon
finir en dix ans et demain qu'est ce que
ce que je pourrais faire ou aussi sûr
que je les ai soleil se lever qu'est ce
que je pourrais faire de très humble
dans mon quotidien qui fait que je fais
un pas de plus dans un sens ou dans un
sens me semble vraiment clients quels
axes en croix c'est sûr que là
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]